a couple of minutes from one of the
world's most famous horse races
spectacle of a different kind
animal rights protesters determined to
cause disruption
first of a number of people scaling a
fence then one protester appearing to
glue themselves to part of the course
they are eventually arrested but the
race watched by millions worldwide was
delayed by 12 minutes
the original plan was to try and stop
the race completely but the activists
still see today as a victory in terms of
raising awareness of the cruelty
involves in in horse racing
you've done it animal Rising wanted to
disrupt the start of this famous event
to highlight what it calls a broken
relationship between humans and animals
and despite the robust policing presence
they did manage to delay the start of
the race merseyside police confirmed
multiple arrests including those who
tried to breach the course boundaries
and others involved in protests outside
it's been a very challenging day but
ultimately the race has taken place with
a slight delay and I'm hoping that
everyone who came today enjoyed their
time at the event clearly a lot of
challenges for
event organizers for police officers and
staff uh but you know my view is that
we've taken some really proactive and
appropriately robust approach to dealing
with a very difficult and challenging
situation
one legendary winner of the national
gave us this verdict on the protests I
wish these people actually would go and
look in a racing yard and see how horses
are looked after not just racing show
jumping any other aspect of Equestria
and see how horses are looked after if
they basically do they want to give a
racehorse to anybody to have them in
their back Garden
um you know horses are there um they're
bred to race and they love it
after all the commotion a win for eight
to one favorite korak Rambler giving
trainer Lucinda Russell and jockey Derek
Fox a second victory at the event
and feel very lucky no uh
can't believe it you know it's the it's
you know it's the biggest race you look
up to as a child and uh you know it's a
dream come true really of the 39
starters 17 finished and following a
four at the first offense racehorse Hill
16 died after the event
it's a race that will be remembered not
just for the winner but the drama off
the course too shinki marike Sky News
ain't true